amount what percent from your personal
experience and your friends experiences
what percent of women require men to
wear condoms what percentage Yeah what
percentage
I have many people told me they didn't
even need to ask and I've actually had a
friend that said that they just the girl
slipped in yeah
so it's like yeah um but then to beef
and there's a lot more women on birth
control
competitive before in it so that might
be another percentage wise though do you
want a specific number like yeah like
would you say 10 20 50 80 maybe four
around forty percent
only 25 like ask to put it on just what
about diseases because I feel because
women are mostly kind of majority might
be chasing that top top guy in it so
they might not even care
um
yeah so yeah it'd be a small it'd be a
small amount of women
because not yeah they they choose who
they are Did anyone say over 50 percent
so women why do you
why do you think women in general so
reckless with their sexual health
I didn't know that
because this is actually High numbers
most shows I've I've gotten lower when
I've asked this question I would say the
average I've heard from guys was like 10
to 20 percent like 40 That's the highest
percentage I've gotten my one of my best
well my best friend is a is a male and
he went
um not in Hill Carnival
he said
one thing that stood out to me said he
went around the corner of a girl
beautiful girl showed me a picture of a
beautiful girl went around the corner
had a quickie oh wow no in the carnival
in the carnival no uh contraception
nothing they just did it did it and then
left and obviously okay yeah she got his
number he's got his number and
everything vice versa whatever but
if it's like that in carnival God will
work
just crazy incredible where like where
did they go behind someone's house
there's many places there's many places
many corners footage of people doing all
sorts of things
they're dancing
it's a form of dance you know it's a
form of dance
I went to do the interviews but like
there's people everywhere they don't
care they don't care there's loads of
food have you not what's that at the
moment
Carnival like I just I won't touch it I
went to my first one to do interviews
but I was I didn't see you've seen it
you wouldn't see it because it's quick
I would be scarred for life
sometimes the best way to hide something
is to do it in the open I don't know
are you speaking from experience
[Laughter]
and then they just get videos like put
on like Twitter or something you don't
understand
well stuff wait does that is Carnival
like crazy here yes yes
I saw the crazy outfits but I didn't
realize that we're just like did you get
it in the Crowd Oh okay I'll tell you
what happened so hi I've heard okay I've
heard a lot about Carnival and everyone
I've never been to a festival before so
this was like an interesting like first
one to go to and
um so when I went I did the interviews
and I always asked like what on Earth
would you do for eight hours straight
like I just in my brain like it doesn't
compute like what are you and everyone
says just Vibes and I was like what does
that even mean like I don't understand
what like vibing like like is that you
just chilling just having fun
yeah I think I think I'm just like
mentally an old person I don't know and
um so the last hour I was like okay I'm
gonna try The Vibes
so I was like I told my cameraman I was
like you can go home you know oh yeah so
because it was like there's like an hour
left in carnival so I was like I did my
interviews let me see and
I was it was horrible yeah like one I
got in this like I wanted to leave like
at the end and I got in this crowd and
there's people everywhere and then
people try to grab you I'm like no yeah
well guys not trying to touch you up and
yeah they work yeah stop it
[Laughter]
but I was just trying to leave and it
was like then I ended up by this like
parade thingy and oh my gosh it was it
was a lot but that was only an hour so I
can't even imagine how people do
like a full but I think the girls they
complained they just bend over start
twitching right when they get grabbed
that's why guys touch you up because
they think you're gonna that's another
thing they like yeah they were strangers
yeah and I was so confused I'm like do
people know each other it's very weird
like black people why do you do that no
I know
why people would never do that there was
this video in a Daily Mail where this
girl was twerking on the policeman yeah
and guy was grinding on the police woman
as well like I'm saying what's going on
if you understand the Caribbean if you
understand the Caribbean you understand
that it's it may not look but it's
actually harmless done yeah that's how
we move yeah so more time more times are
not when you come to Carnival you come
with a mindset that that's going to
happen but there's a lot of things
how is it harmless if the dude like took
the girl behind the you're telling me
people having sex everywhere
I'm talking about the Vibes inside that
baby
normally go to Carnival is that for
example if you go to certain places in
the Caribbean listen to their music and
dance with it it's a lot of it's a lot
of provocative dancing but if you have
that mindset that you're gonna you're
gonna go there some people want to dance
with you that's normally what yeah tends
to happen but there's some there's some
people that go overboard we can we can
admit that but doesn't it all end up in
sex if it's not this moment The Exchange
number it'll be later it's a lot of
sexual attention not always
true or at least an erection
well if the girl is attractive and she
makes you exactly
right by the end of the day not every
not every man from there thinks okay
okay since it's harmless are you guys
cool dancing with like a 60 year old
lady a six-year-old lady yeah because
it's harmless it's not sexual yeah
but the thing is your grandma
when you talk about lizzo and when you
talk about a six-year-old woman that has
nothing to do with the action that's to
do with my me wanting to dance with her
so I'm saying so when we say harmless
I'm talking about if it's harmless or
you're gonna let your grandma
remember harmless
no but you need to remember what
harmless means it means what is it
without harm so I can dance with lizzo
and a six-year-old and she doesn't get
hurt at all that's harmless me not
wanting to dance
to it though that's what we're trying to
ask in some cases there is in some cases
in all of the cases it's sexually why
would you exactly that's the point
that's the point when you said when you
said harmless like I was just
interpreting that as like it's not
sexual so I understand like most dancing
no one's getting hurt yeah like mostly
but the reason why I say that is because
there's a lot of cultures outside of the
Caribbean that wouldn't dance that way
so when they see our thoughts that way
there already is a negative connotation
yeah but if you are part of our culture
you understand what that means okay
maybe harmless wasn't the right word
yeah but a lot of the so the way how we
dance it may not lead to anything sexual
after that it may be just that dance are
you wife so are you cool with like wife
and a girl that goes to Carnival every
year and does the full two days
it's harm it's harmless it's not sexual
if I'm there
no no no no this is just what she's been
doing the harmless harmless last last
couple years before she met you
there's no Vibes
don't change it don't change it you're
not there this is before she met you
yeah so you were you didn't know her
she's been going to Carnival she tells
you yeah I've been here for five years
Vibes personally I would okay if she's
Caribbean like me I would okay but she's
not Caribbean does it change it it
depends on how well she understands the
Caribbean culture and Carnival okay only
because I agree because like because
because I am Jamaican I understand that
that form of dancing so maybe harmless
may not be the right word to to have
used yeah but I have done so me
personally I've danced with many girls
in that way and once we finish we went
our separate ways right so I'm saying
you go to your with your girl to the
carnival if you're okay for a guy to
dance no it's harmless
[Music]
yeah so she just said it leads to
something it always leaves something
slowly I disagree because I've danced
with friends and it's never lit to
anything yeah [__] it doesn't always
lead to sex but the sexual in the tone
is what we're talking about there's some
there's something going on if someone if
a girl's bum is Right granny against
we're growing there's something going on
right okay okay I just wish I could pull
a video right now I'm just a girls
twerking at carnival and you're telling
me there's no sexual undertone the dance
alone is sexual
is not
and this is just what I saw that
incredible why did you not get hard if
it's not sexual why are you getting hard
please not always but half of the time
half of the time that's because that's
because there's someone you're attracted
to but if you're dancing with someone
you're not attracted to you're not gonna
get oh you wouldn't dance with someone
you're not attracted to that's what you
said yeah
I might dance with a friend a guy friend
female friends
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible